And we're ready to go.
So let me go to the member site for any new information that we want you to know.
Also, if you want to do a coaching call, fill out the coaching call request form,
like members first paid to the member site.
And remember, you have access to all our courses and probably the most appropriate one.
I mean, stop fighting cancer. Well, of course, when you guys know all that,
you've got that all of the members site here.
But the chronic disease at all of the courses, the most appropriate.
And I think because it's got just so much new information about all of your disease there.
It's literally really cutting edge.
I think about trying to do it on the board, but it's there's.
If you watch some of the videos are there, you're going to know more than the majority of even functional medicine doctors out there.
So it's really some good stuff.
And they're also, you know, use our blog.
We have about 900 or so blog posts.
A lot of those videos and stuff that you can find things if you're looking for something.
Okay, let's jump to the questions.
I've noticed itching and a rash.
Maybe even mild hives that ended just below the top of both of my shoulders spreading a little bit to top of shoulder frontside.
As well as top and behind my right knee.
And itches and I scratch until there are multiple little scabs, same scam pattern at all locations.
This is new in the last few weeks.
What are if it's the lip system detoxing maybe from the SCFT now using a couple of months or some other product aspect of the protocol.
That's always a possibility.
That you are detoxing certainly.
And the top of the shoulders upper trapezius.
Even down into the upper round void.
Muscles can be referred.
Pain referred.
It's possible.
I mean, I would consider doing like cast oil packs over the liver or just hot pads over the liver just to.
You know, because you'll hit the gallbladder than to just to make sure that that's not it.
It doesn't really fit with the right D though, so I don't know if that is the issue or not.
Certainly it's really easy when your your body chemistry is constantly changing.
And look at, you know, just switch it up your deodorant or not the owner but detergent.
Because where your clothes rub, that can be an issue if you're sweating at all with the change in weather and stuff that can be an issue to you, you've been develop a little hypersensitivity for a short period of time to something that you haven't been hypersensitivity for a long time.
Certainly supporting the detox pathways is the best way to go though.
So I think you're we are on the right track there, but do investigate other possible sensitivities is still fits to detoxification pathways still to, but.
Investing in some of those other things as well.
Can you explain why.
My recent CDC tests.
My local see this person is in another country, so it's a different spelling so this leukocytes was 2.57 in the average rate is 4 to 10.8.
These are fields, monophils, lymphocytes, so your leukocytes are your total white blood cell.
So that's that's a combination of your lymphocytes, your neutrophils, your basophils, your monocytes.
Those can all be with the normal rate, but you can have a total overall white blood cell count that's a little low.
So what can you do to increase your total white blood cell count?
You really you're what increases your total white blood cell count is is dealing with what could lower your total white blood cell count.
So what can lower your total white blood cell count is chronic infection.
So in acute infection, you'll have an elevated white blood cell, chronic infection, you can have a suppressed white blood cell.
You're also going to have a suppressed white blood cell quality rule of leukemia is some of the different leukeias.
That's not uncommon either.
But if your basophils, your monocytes, your lymphocytes are within normal ranges, and I think your neutrophils are in normal range as well.
Then you think of just some chronic issues, maybe a chronic fungal infection, a chronic parasitic infection.
So what you would do is try to deal with that and investigate a little further on dealing with that.
I know this person is going to be back in the States, sometimes soon, it might be who you to get some different testing to see what would be appropriate in this case.
So we might want to set up a one-on-one with me, well, we're some positive testing that we might want to move forward with.
Also, what are your thoughts about the effects of dark chocolate on the calcium absorption?
I have osteoporosis and osteopoeia, according to the dextascade through years ago.
And heard that chocolate, it appears with calcium absorption like the brain shows.
Well, it really depends on what you're eating. I don't think that eating a little bit of dark chocolate on a daily basis is going to make a big deal with calcium absorption.
Good dark dark chocolate has a lot of antioxidants in it and could actually be good for you can satisfy a little bit of your sweet tunes if you're trying to stay away from sugar.
So I wouldn't be too concerned about that.
And I know you just jumped on and I just answered your questions. Sorry, the first one.
So you can listen to that afterwards. I give you some hints on that.
My dogs, my mom's dog has a kidney and bladder infection. The rife has programs for both of those.
When running these rife programs for dog, potentially be helpful.
Yes, that's what I've mentioned to many of you over the years.
Another thing that has convinced me that the rife is a valuable tool.
You know, with anything, okay, isn't the right that's working.
You know, if you did a course of therapy that included the right and you, you know, you had success with that course of therapy, you start asking objective questions like, was it the right that helped you?
The diet that helped me was it just my attitude change that helped me was there some sort of just, you know, emotional effect that that gave me comfort.
Is that what really helped me?
And it's impossible to come to a perfect conclusion would answer it.
I would ask you the question like that. But when you look at using the rife on children where there's going to have really no other effect.
You know, you might usually like a dog or something. You're not doing anything else with them. You're not doing any other changes with them.
And you see them get better from a serious disease like cancer. It's pretty cool.
And over the years, it's had at least 15 patients saying that the rife cured their dog or cat of cancer that they were told to put the animal down.
They refused to do it. They started running a program cancer program for the dog or cat. I've had actually two doctors come to me and buy a right for their both of them bought it for their dog and programs the right for their dog.
And so it's pretty cool. Would you see success like that on an animal? You know, there was no other, you know, interference. You know, it was the right that did it. It's the for the dog got better. So
what are your thoughts about supplemented with end and so end and it is nicotinamide model nucleotide to supplement that is a precursor for NAD.
So NAD really had supplement in the supplement business right now. What NAD does is it increases at ATP by stimulating an increasing limit of all like pathways.
It is, oh, Angie types of Leo or God diagnosed two years ago, still going strong using the right.
So I am not a fan of using NAD with cancer. So it stimulates a bit about pathway. It stimulates growth pathways. It can be really good for people that are working out.
And try to build muscle and try to build have more stand up stamina in their workouts. But with somebody with cancer. No, I'm not a fan of using any NAD stimulants for that reason. It's something that could increase growth factors and increase the rate of replication of cells, which is could be really great.
If you don't have cancer, right. But if you have cancer, then it can have issues. Even if you don't have cancer, you have to be careful of some of these supplements NAD.
I know people that have used NAD and, oh, you know, what is good than three must be better. Well, it could increase heart rate and can give a person attack cardio.
Be careful with some of these things, even if you're in a state of really good health. But I would not use NAD or cancer person.
How does taking vitamin C, when you have live disease, is that a no no? What does it do? So if you have live disease is taking vitamin C, a bad thing.
Well, it depends. So if you have a cute case of live, so I categorize live disease.
If you want in depth of what I'm going to share, you can go to the three phases of live course right here.
But I categorize live disease in three phases. That's the name of the course of the name of the book that I wrote about live disease.
So phase one live is a cute line. So you just got bit by a tick. You have Borrelia bacteria and or coin factions circulating your bloodstream doing something to stimulate your immune system is the right thing to do. So in that case, you know, you should take vitamin C.
You should probably get it on an antibiotic right away. You have a cute phase one line.
If you don't treat it and the bacteria and or coin factions, then get inside the get inside of a cell. So they go through the cell membrane.
Now you have chronic what has been known as chronic live. I call that phase two line. So it's inside the cell, you know, immune stimulants will help when it's outside the cell, your immune stimulants and or antibiotics will not help if the bacteria and or viral or other bacterial coin factions go intra cellular within the cell.
You're immune system is not going to break through your cell membranes and attack the bacteria in the cytoplasm of the cell.
You're, you know, pickled on when you're in product line and it becomes more difficult to treat.
This is where people go on long-term antibiotics because every time it pulls outside the cell to reproduce more than you can kill it, but it just damages your gut damages and a lot of other things, but some people have a bit help by that.
People are on immune stimulants, you know, heavy immune stimulants. Well, that could have negative effects too because you could move into what's called phase three.
But what I call autoimmune line. So anytime you now developed antibodies to self tissue, wherever that line was found to be intercellular, your immune system continues to try to kill it, starts to create antibodies against that tissue.
And once you have antibodies against self tissue, you're in an autoimmune state that you're going to be using, you know, immune stimulants like vitamin C, you can actually make yourself worse.
So it is inherently a little bit more difficult to treat somebody with with autoimmune disease and obviously, so to say, you're all over the entire course about that.
But you, it's even more difficult to treat somebody with an autoimmune disease when they have cancer, but I do think that cancer has an autoimmune component to it and a lot of people.
It's, it's a balancing act to try to get your immune system to kill the cancer with while you're not stimulating your immune system to kill self tissue at the same time.
That's why I am, I'm not this humongous fan of intravenous vitamin C even for cancer patients.
And I haven't recommended it for a lot of you, but a lot of you are doing it because you just feel led to do it, which is great.
You know, you have to really wait on whether it's helping you or not can be about saying it's not, but if you have an autoimmune component going on as well, then it can be a source of increased inflammation, systemic inflammation and tissue destruction to the tissue that you have antibodies against.
Well, that's all very complicated. Well, that's why we have an entire course about it. So that's why I started off this conversation by saying if you're going to look at some of these courses, you guys all know all the stuff about stuff by the cancer now start digging into the autoimmune component.
And that might be an answer people, some people are stuck.
One of the cancer docu series, Dr. Ellen Park Jensen gave this recipe for liver cleansing blended smoothie.
I'm not going to read it all I've been making the strength for myself for a couple of times a week for several months now in the last week.
I am all of a sudden nauseous after I drink it.
Any thoughts on why this could happen when I did it, it didn't bother me for so long.
Um, yeah, I don't see anything in there that's, you know, would spark red flag or anything.
Usually when you think of nauseous thus after you eat something, you think of gallbladder.
So the only thing I would say is maybe I would ask the question, do you get nauseous after you eat a fatty meal?
Well, I really thought of that. Well, try to keep an eye on that. You do have a table spoon of olive oil in here.
And if, you know, that will stimulate gallbladder contraction.
If you have any blockage for the doctor or any slugishness of gallbladder issues, that can be, that could be an issue.
What do you do for that? Well, you can do coffee, animals, you can do, um,
hot packs over the liver gallbladder area. You could go to the seven paces of detox occasion course and look at these four, which is gallbladder function and flow.
And see some hints about that with that too, but that would be my first spot here feeling nauseous and particularly.
Okay, can daily coffee, animals cause colon issues or bowel issues over time would have done properly.
Um, but anything could cause anything, I guess I wouldn't say that I don't know when we never cause any issues. I mean, you could have some irritation, even if you do it correctly.
You know, leave that people and do a coffee, animals for years on a daily basis and not have any issues.
If you feel irritation or something, you could switch from coffee to something else for a period of time, like a tea, animal, like something like that, or you could back off on it for a period of time.
Um, yeah, I don't, you know, we have some people that have been doing a daily for a long time. So, I don't, if you feel like you're having some issues, then possibly.
Is high quality organic collagen from grass that beef brought okay to supplement.
Um, as a general question, the answer would be really because of what type of cancer they have. So if the person has any colorectal colon cancer, um, I'd say no.
Um, probably too much food to be needed for that.
Um, if the person is in a state of, you know, pretty much remission of their cancer and they're just feeling, hey, I just, my skin and hair and nails, I couldn't prove I'm really unhappy with.
Uh, you maybe they went through chemo, the image of chemo that I'd say, yeah, I don't think there's anything wrong with doing that.
Um, so just better with having balance. If you have active cancer colorectal type cancer, I would say no, don't use that.
But tuberic increased my tumor bleeding.
Well, the most common thing that would increase bleeding would be garlic.
Uh, supplementation, um, because garlic is your is going to, um, reduce, uh, plant that's a little bit.
Um, tuberic, does tuberic have any, uh, anti clotting factors.
I don't think so. You could Google that, but I don't think so. I don't think tuberic is going to increase.
Um, we have some people that put a tumoric paste on their open wound.
So, uh, it never heard of anybody having increased bleeding with that.
So I don't think so.
Would there be a former breast surgeon oncologist turned into greater, who would be best for me to quiz about conventional stuff like surgery?
For example, I sat on a webinar by Jen Simmons and she does do concerts.
So Jen Simmons would be what I would recommend. The only issue is is that I, well, the last time I talked to Jen Simmons, I said, hey, I really like her.
And I said, hey, can I refer some breast cancer patients to you and you can do consults with them.
And I think she's limited to be able to do consults in Pennsylvania, New York and New Jersey or something like that.
So you could certainly call her office and ask.
And, um, but I think, you know, because she is a licensed medical doctor still, she has to go by that law.
So, um, but you can certainly ask her.
I also on the home page of the member site, there is a breast surgeon, um, it's a female breast surgeon from California, who another patient really liked and had a consultation with a really, really liked that person.
But that ladies, uh, that doctor's information up on the home page of the member site. So that would be another person to look at.
So either one of those I would say someone recently recommended college and muscle builder since I protect my bad hip from muscle deterioration since it helps build muscle will help cancer grow too.
I would be careful with collagen because collagen can stimulate growth. So, um, it would be, it would be more important to be careful with collagen if I had a colorectal type cancer.
I would add no carcinoma. I would stay away from collagen and breast cancer. Could you have a little collagen. Yeah, yeah.
When I take it daily, probably not, but I would not take it and I would for you, I would not do collagen.
I wanted you to know that I'm planning on sending you my blood work, testimony, a new cheek swab, this coming Monday, okay, great. Thank you very much. Thank you, get all you do.
I know that you are an amazing, have an amazing staff that are in my first. Thank you so much.
Is there a place in any of your courses where you explain about hormones, formal blockers and why did work frozen cons etc.
I have multiple blog posts about that. If you just search that little thing, that little eyeglass thing and search a rheumatase to start with that word, you'll come up with several.
I think I have a couple of videos on a rope face inhibitors too.
I don't think I go into the metabolic details to and how it works.
But there really aren't any pods to taking them. They're all close. I mean, everybody could take them quite honestly if there's, I mean, I don't like everybody wants to take more supplements.
I don't take them. I probably should because why would everybody want to take them because everybody's exposed to exogenous.
I mean, it's like we're just bleed with astrogens. I mean, I swear the power that we want to estrogens by the entire world, take away, you know, any male testosterone.
So, but, you know, it really doesn't have any negatives. You know, I guess the negative would be it's certainly not going to work as the same as as far as shutting down all, you know, estrogen like a like a robotase inhibitor would do, but that's why people like it because it's not giving you all the negatives of shutting down all your estrogens.
I use silver nitrate applicators when my breast tumor bleeds a lot, but I put coconut oil on the wood before I bandage it.
Do you have any other suggestions? I think silver nitrate, even hydrogen peroxide, topically, can be a great thing to just make sure that you don't get a secondary infection. So when you ever have an open will you just don't want secondary infections.
So silver nitrate can be a good thing. Hydrogen peroxide can be a good thing.
Just you could actually put some just three percent hydrogen peroxide in a little spray bottle so you could just spray it out there.
That can be a good thing to either healthy recipes on your site. Yeah, the blog post actually grace has done a ton of videos on our Instagram page.
The videos are out there, and I think she put them all on the blog post to videos on healthy treats and just really nice short shorts that are really easy to make healthy treats.
And she really has recipes for chicken or meat or whole meal recipes. I think there's a couple, but a lot I just like some simple things for some nice things to have.
Any other questions?
I really wanted me to repeat the comment from Kelly that said you have an amazing staff. Yes, I do have an amazing staff.
I'm very, very thankful that has blessed our clinic in many, many ways and the biggest ways of the people that work here. Everybody really cares about you guys.
So, um, update on AJ. Hey, but I did talk to Ann about moves for every golden three weeks ago.
And AJ, so for those who don't know and used to work here, we still consider her a part of the team that she is kind of a permanently bright.
So, her son, 18 year old, they've dealt with the Duke Milo and leukemia. Super sick almost died.
Did go through chemo.
Very cute attack and he's doing really well right now.
Three weeks ago, I think he had just taken a trip with the cousin down to Arizona. I think they were going golf.
That was really good news. So, um, that was three weeks ago, I have a talk to her.
Thank you for asking.
Thank you for praying for them. So safe to use a vacuum sealer on food. Yeah.
Yeah, I think so.
So, quite honestly, you know, if you're on Instagram or Facebook and you're in any health groups, I mean, let's be honest, you hear bad things about everything.
It's just gets to the point where it's like you can't live anymore because you know there's bad things and everything.
You have to have a balance. You just have to, you're going to go crazy.
So yes, would it be better if you just put everything in glass and did that. Yeah, but, you know, are you storing the plastics in a heated space.
Yes, I'm storing the plastics in a hot garage, whether it's probably not best to put losing plastics.
Are you putting it in a cold area of cool area. Yes, well, you're not going to have a lot of leach of bad chemicals from the plastics where you have a lot of leach of bad chemicals from plastics is with heat.
So like the plastic top on your coffee cup.
That's good.
So leaving your water bottle, your plastic water bottles that you got from Costco in the car in the summer, not good.
It's just a matter of trying to find whatever balance is best for you. You are each other. Yes, I do because I like it. Should I know, but you have to find the balance that's best for you.
And that beat yourself up, you know, set over and over again. This is, you know, your diet and your lifestyle cannot become a religion that it's that it's idolatry.
And that's not healthy.
That's really not healthy. So you have to find that balance of what's good, what's right to use, you know, common sense, use knowledge and science that we know of today.
So we, you know, we're really big into our garden needed stuff by wife and I. We make this chinchuri sauce. That's great over chicken and vegetables and all sorts of you can just put it on anything.
It's crock pot meals. It's so good. But we put it in Ziploc bags and freeze it.
Would it be better if you can't it. Yeah, but then you have to have, then you have to pressure can't it and this is takes a much time. So when you're can't even doing so many things during, you know, harvest season is insane in our house.
You just have to balance things out. I don't think we're getting a lot of estrogen disruptors from our Ziploc bags that we're putting in the freezer.
I don't know. Maybe science is going to say that's the worst thing and we'll change our ways. But right now I don't think it is. And we're going to go with it. So it's just about having that balance. We used to use the vacancy there on those, but it's hard to choose to look pretty good.
We used to vacancy there on other things. So there's a little bit longer shelf life. So yeah, you guys are let me off early today, but it says I don't think we've got often less than an hour that I asked you.
Any other questions. All right. So hopefully you guys are getting out and gardening wherever whatever part of the world that you're in.
It's just reading up here in Minnesota and Wisconsin. I hope it's creating up there. And you can get out and get some gardening done. It's so good for you. Get yourself dirty.
Some probiotics of the soil and good bacteria. It's so good for your real system.
So any of the breast cancer. Yes, so any of them is good for breast cancer. So that's good for all cancers, honestly.
Last couple of mornings, I've woken up with anxiety, which is odd to me. Is there any nutrient or something I may be missing with anxiety? You think of
glutamate is your first thing you think of. At least that's the first thing I could come.
So you know, it's our excitatory or transmitter. So what excited to read or transmitter, you know, to your brain or cause anxiety, that cause I will see the issues.
Wake you up in the morning. So you need to do it, but they're not bad, but just access amounts.
Will wake you up that make you anxious. So where would you get glutamates? Well, you could have it so if you.
you ate like, you know, you went out to eat got Chinese food, guaranteed you had
has glutamates in it. Anything prepared foods probably has glutamates because
glutamates stimulate your your brain. So they put glutamates in food so that you go,
wow, this is really good. This tastes fantastic. And doesn't really taste fantastic.
It's just making your brain think it takes fantastic since stimulating your
brain through glutamate pathway. Second thing is you could have from a nutrient standpoint
you think of adaptogens. So adaptogens are adaptogenic herbs that can help just
calm your body and calm the anxiety. And you're going to look from a spiritual
standpoint. Are there spiritual forces that you're tacking you and you're going
to pray against those as well? So you can dose three categories.
Glutamates come from food, prepared foods. I'm not getting any of that.
Glutamates also come from glutamine. So if you ate a lot of meat, animal protein will
break down to glutamates, eventually, especially if you have gaging defects.
No, didn't eat any protein. So I just ate vegetables yesterday and you would eat
a protein and they woke up with this. I didn't eat any prepared meals.
We'll look at make sure you don't have spices that have glutamates, not a sodium
glutamate, just the most common thing you'll see. Don't you have any of that?
Then you think of adaptogens possibly and the spiritual connection.
Thoughts on photodynamic therapy depends on what you're describing as photodynamic
therapy. Photodynamic therapy is described by the
maximal cancer clinics as the use of the laser lights internally and with a medication.
We've had a few people do it, very mixed results. I don't know really giant parades on photodynamic
therapy. There is photodynamic therapy loosely. There's clinics that are loosely using that
term when they're using a light therapy. So you would red light therapy and photodynamic
therapy. Well, I guess technically it is, but that's not really how Mexico cancer clinics
are describing it. It's totally different. We use the laser, is that photodynamic therapy
well technically, but that's not really how they're doing it for the Mexico cancer clinics.
You can't legally do photodynamic therapy. The way they do it is the Mexico cancer clinics.
I don't believe you can do it in the US. Worth testing levels. Levels of what motivates is
a worth testing for trans winners on my opinion. No, selenium. Yeah, you can test selenium.
Probably your minerals go up and down so often through the day. I don't think it's accurate.
So I don't know that it's really worth testing selenium. For the level that you're going to
pay for the test, I mean, a bottle of selenium is pretty inexpensive. I don't think it's
personally, I just take selenium. I don't feel like that to do that. So cost wise, it's
pretty cheap as to do that. There's no really don't follow and take too much study with
imbalance, taking too much selenium. Anything to help my hot flashes due to the horrible blockers.
I'm taking demurecommended extra ashwagada, table spoon and bulk there. Not too bad, but at night,
the bothersome sweating makes me wake up cold and what it goes away. The thing is the things,
again, we talked about this before, but if you're going to take something that's going to
help with hot flashes, you're kind of diminishing the role of the purpose of the horrible blockers.
So the horrible blockers are to eliminate estrogens or reduce estrogens and hence you get hot
flashes. If you take, you know, something that's going to stimulate estrogens like, you know, soy,
ice of flavonoids, flavones, then you're simulating estrogens, you're kind of
buying what you're trying to do. So that doesn't make any sense to do that. You get, you know,
that is the outcome of reducing estrogens. And you could take some adaptogens like
Hoshwagada isn't adaptogens. So, but I mean, there's nothing you really have to suffer through it
because anything that would help with those are going against what you're trying to do.
That's the acte. The concentrated looking form has alcohol in it. This is probably the worst thing
about it. Maybe evaporate. So it is, it is the herbs are in an alcohol base and most of the liquid
herbs that you'll ever get are in an alcohol base. That's what a tincture is is almost always an
alcohol base of an herb. If you did a water base, it would just go bad too fast. So
I don't, I, it's just as you still will get around it really. And the, the benefit of an alcohol
tincture, it does pull the nutrients out of the herb so it makes it more accessible through. So
there's huge benefits to an alcohol base tincture. Now, you know, it's difficult. Some people that
are, that have alcoholic backgrounds, the alcohol can stimulate, you know, that craving it again. So
we have to kind of balance that out. If a cancer is triggered by a virus, isn't the virus still
possibly probably active? If the keyword is if. So not all cancers are
stem triggered by a virus, even though some people write that in books and blogs and stuff. So
remember that. But if it is triggered by a virus, does it mean the virus is still active? No,
it doesn't. So if a cancer was initially triggered by a bio toxin of any kind, whether, so
remember, anything that gets inside of a cell, whether it's a chemical toxicity, whether it's a
bio toxin, like, you know, some other bacteria or virus. If it damages the nucleus in the cell,
that cell that nucleus is damaged, and it goes into rapid replication, it's rapidly replicating
another damaged cell that's rapidly replicating. So it's not the virus is necessarily even even in
the body anymore. So it can be person can still have, let's say a person with stomach cancer and
they have H. Pylora has the cause, which is the number one causes stomach cancer worldwide.
They still have H. Pylora most likely because how H. Pylora is, you know, it's most likely that
they still have the active H. Pylora that it's ironic that 90% of people with stomach cancer,
the doctor, the oncologist, never treats the H. Pylora. However, it doesn't always mean with other
cancers that may have started from a bio toxin, it doesn't always mean the bio toxin is present.
That's what's called an active antigen. So if the person still has an active virus or active
bio toxin, it's called an active antigen. How you measure that is is partly through a CBC,
a complete blood count, which is if, next I'll remember, like this question back we had back here.
First, it has white blood cell count, total leukocytes are total white blood cell count. Normal is
four to 10, really, it should be about, it should be about five to eight. Different labs give
different normal ranges. But if you have a total white blood cell count, over eight, you really do
have some sort of active infection. It might be a low grade infection, but you have some active
infection. Then you look at the slit of those white blood cells, the vasophils,
monocytes, lymphocytes, and neutrophils. If the person has elevated lymphocytes, then most likely,
they have a viral infection. If they have elevated neutrophils, then most likely they have a bacterial
infection. That's how you look at a CDC. But if the person, like this person,
and this one, they don't have elevated white blood cells, they have suppressed white blood cells.
That can be from a product by parasitic infection or folgulin infection, not really viral or
bacterial. You can't do a CD-8, CD-4 ratio too. That's a different, a little deeper test for that,
and you can see if a person has an active infection with that too. What about squamous cell from
HPV? How do you know if it's still not a problem after chemo and radiation? Well, you can do
testing for HPV. You can look at just what I just said with the CDC and see if there's an active
antigen. You can do a CD-4 CD-8 ratio. That could tell you if you have an active antigen. But again,
squamous cell from HPV, which is a very common source and cause for squamous cell carcinoma,
especially the head neck. It can have been from a long time ago, and you don't have any
active HPV. If somebody knows that they have squamous cell cancer, even if they were told that
the oncologist doesn't think that's HPV. We relate it. I always put HPV frequencies in their
right pilgrim. I don't really know. So, I still hit it with the right as well. I remember chemo or
radiation. It's not going to kill a virus. It's going to kill the cancer, but it's not going to kill
the virus or bacteria. But in fact, it's kind of the other way around. If you chemo,
you have a virus or bacteria, it's probably going to increase. I don't like that I don't know if I can
control it. I'm glad I have a throat biopsy on a tumor. This would be a section and not a needle.
Are there things I should be aware of, cautious of, insist on, et cetera?
You know, we discussed this at your case review, but they're going to take that little clip off of
that spot. I would just be really careful. Make sure you're not taking, I didn't put you on
any guard. Make sure you're not taking guard, because it's a blood thinner. You don't want to just
remove, have that being come up clean, and just have not healed. We're a good platelet activity
there. So, they will probably tell you that too. They don't want you one. They might say,
if they don't want you running any supplements, but it's really, I mean, guard,
is your number one blood thinner. We'll make it three some little bit, but guard,
is really your big blood thinner. So, let's see, we're going to ask you another question.
How often can I do the footpath to high-end throwaway? We recommend really once a day, Max,
them on my thing. I would say that we've had people do more than once a day in acute situations,
but you know, so many of the programs are an hour long, so take up part of your day. You certainly
can be doing a hot pack over your liver at the same time. You can do some other things with it,
but you can't be running the right flake, because you're using the right for the high-end throwaway.
So, what you can do two things at once, if you don't pee enough or something like that,
you can use that as well. All right, I think we'll call it a night. Thanks for being on everybody.
Keep up with a good fight, know that we're praying for you, and cherish your prayers for us as well.
All right, I love you all. Speaking for everybody with our team, and we'll talk to you next week.